yeah how's it goin with me sighs Beth
Morosky we got a new person with the
banhammer today what's your name grace
yeah
it's grace the intern don't have with
grace with either of us or we'll get you
that's right because grace is learning
the banhammer and he's excited to use it
and Beth is always excited to you she
loves to be she's got a lot of like
pent-up like let's put it down
uh hello waffle tarts pervy Eclipse
how's it going Bilbo effing Howard boy
uh ally Bartlett ally Bartlett's a cool
name president Hammer
Hosea Bartlett ally bartlett sounds like
a pirate name and that's great because
we're playing a little pirate game today
we're playing some seeing thieves is
gonna be very exciting I got my
all-black on today partly because I
forgot to bring an ironic t-shirt but
also because it is a pirate game today
and they have the old Jolly Roger which
is a skull and crossbones which is this
is me doing skull and crossbones do you
think that that's all let's play so see
if these if you're playing if you have
seen thieves and you want to play with
us my user name is Blair it's all right
in the corner up there it's my last name
and it looks like as Robert Smigel once
told me looks like God misspelled your
name it's got a y a e in the middle of
it just like what like a yeah you want
it to be a yurt and frankly I want to be
a year so that's the thing all right
I've played a lot of sea of thieves in
the past couple years at e3 s la C of E
3 s played some key city 3s I'm having a
stroke I've had nine copies no I see
these and I'm so happy it's finally done
if finally out because it's it's was
such a cool game every single time I got
to play it and it's basically a pirate
multiplayer game which is very excited
epic Vico maybe I don't know she we
asked Cohen if he wants to show up he
won't show well asking them hey Gregory
Caesar is Caesar Eze how's it going
this game Arun D Arun is this is a
pirate game I'm gonna be this dude over
here this guy this guy
appealed to me it's kind of a guy fieri
this was me before I lost the weight
situation here pirates elected yeah he's
got great hair this is me in ten months
and it and the way he drinks it's me
last night oh no oh no I got to turn off
the message remember we got the message
thing oh no oh no all right well I got
Pangos adding the other friend I gotta
get out of here real quick and just turn
okay we got a notification issue sorry
everybody got to figure out this
notification thing too many friends yeah
can you go back to full screen real
quick while I figure out how to do this
notification thing my man thank you
we're very excited tonight because we
have a brand new show on the old program
last night one of my favorite I one of
the things I love about our show is and
how do I turn off the notifications one
of my favorite things about our show is
the fact that we break a lot of new
musical guests and last night we had
Natalie brass on who was awesome Natalie
brass was very cool she had like a pink
dress that time and was rocking it out
and how in the world do I turn off these
notifications gosh darnit xbox xbox
you're killing me bro
and tonight who do we have in the show
this evening tonight we've got we got a
big Judd Apatow our best pal like guys
Ritter
Krysten Ritter from Jessica Jones you
know one time I saw Chris and I were
both at a light and I'm not telling this
story well I was at a light a red light
and I was like rocking arts rocking out
super-hard to blink-182 which is
whatever my windows were town I look
over I just see Krysten Ritter next to
me looking at me and she just smiled and
gave me a little none I was like oh my
god Jessica Jones she's the best that's
amazing
here we go system we're gonna go to a
notification thing I jut Apatow he did
an amazing a little while ago jibber
jabber with Conan where him and Conan
talked all about all about comedy and
he's got a master class yeah which is
pretty great I signed up for a master
class thing and it's awesome I've been
watching a lot of masterclasses
notifications off good we got it glad
that's buried in a very deep submenu
alright let's resume to see a themes all
right here we go
do we want a galleon or is that gal Leon
that's a galleon or is it a woman named
Leon
Galia get it gallant get it okay
small sloop crew or sail alone let's do
a crew man oh my god this is gonna be
weird let's do it hey nikka
nook Asuka good to see ya hey Ron that's
right
welcome to see a thieves okay great
alright let's invite some friends can I
invite a friend can how do I in but can
I recruit new crew we're recruiting I
see hiding me cat goes me Wow
well hello by the way speaking of me Wow
Super Troopers 2 is coming out soon oh
my god that's first of all Super
Troopers is a movie done by an improv
group called broken lizard or a sketch
group and it's a classic a 90 early
2000s movie and they play idiot a bunch
of dumbasses as state troopers and they
play games with the people they pull
over and they pull over
our good friend pale force Jim Gaffigan
and they say the one guy gives the other
challenge to the other guy goes 9 meows
and so he has to work in me out so how
fast you're going meow he said what he's
like so you have to work in meow while
he pulls over Jim Gaffigan hilarious
may the sea treat you and your crew with
grog and booty well thanks game haulers
dr. Zaius Super Troopers is the best and
I hope the second one although I gotta
say something about super troopers it's
amazing until they have to like get a
plot going and then it's like all right
it kind of falls into it also has who am
I thinking of Brian he played he's like
a Shakespearean actor he's in every
movie he's in Manhunter as Hannibal
Lecter he's in Troy as Agamemnon nope
not Anthony Hopkins Brian guys help me
out Brian who's the guy I'm thinking of
please did captain O'Brien call Brian
Cox a prize gathered by the lowly
killing in Milligan whoo this is cool
all right Ron chapter 2 already what
happened to chapter 1 I just opened this
game look at those meaty forearms and I
got a nanner all right this would be
cool oh this is great all right
controls are a little janky here we go
hold the view equipment now I got a
banana what else I got
I got a shovel all right all right well
talk to Tasha
I'd like a refill what I'll take a grog
Neptunes barnacle teaser that's right
yeah this is killing it without makeup
exactly he's a done dort Don Tony an
actor I don't know they means I don't
know sissing chief okay
I'm not sure what's happening here let
me know if you hear anything all right
will do okay I thought I was gonna be on
a ship is there a ship somewhere all of
a sudden it's dark and I'm stuck in a
bar I basically stuck it like Jimmy
Buffett's Margaritaville all right here
we go I'm working about the candle at
fire safety we're all worried I've lit
my apartment on fire more times than I
can count this is a little creepy what
am I going there's something on fire on
the water how do I get onto a ship I
thought this was sea of thieves not
bridges of Thieves
I'm going back up wait didn't I just
come down here oh my god this is so
exhausting already a little bit brighter
Oh what is happening now we're going
away I guess this is how I'm supposed to
go okay can I just jump down here am I
gonna die I'm jumping down oh I got hurt
all right I gotta get God like stuck in
some goddamn hellacious II walk village
there's candles everywhere I want
adventure Beth I want swashbuckling and
I want a lot of mateys in args and peg
legs yeah I guess so
your head is pretty nice I'm oh there we
go
the music is started oh all right
there's no music ah I really could use a
boat where's our sloop
all right so far we got jump
we got menus there's no melee here there
are vendors itself wij quest your ship
is at the docks okay
the perpetual II walk trap go to the
glowing smoke in the water exactly I'm
worried I think I need a ship Rev my god
it's dark here would it kill them to
start me out on a ship I mean come on
man look I know you're I know you want
to have a whole world but just get your
boy on a ship
oh and everything's on fire I will say
it is decorated very nicely and you can
see the clothes the Stars which are
really pretty yeah it's kind of like
it's probably Caribbean probably like a
Caribbean breeze I'm a sailor P helped
on the beach you know what I need is
like a Wilson I need like a volleyball
to talk to us okay wait all right we got
a new pope I'm trapped this is madness
guys there's got to be a better way then
I already jump down here oh my god see a
thieves getting just serve me in a boat
come on man I'm in the water all right
I'm gonna just swim out to whatever this
is you know what you can just start me
on a ship is it that hard it's a pirate
game just get me on a ship you don't
have to be all mysterious about it Jesus
Christ here we go we're swimming out to
a mermaid or whatever this dude is in
the water
it's a guy Poseidon or yeah because
that's what you normally think of how to
get onto a ship is you swim out in the
water to a mermaid come on dude what are
you doing
mkb nygma thank you yeah I want to do
some plundering hey Sarge errific who
I'm on sergeant figs dreams Coco stream
team all right yeah we made it to a ship
to live in ten minutes
all right really wanted to start
plundering here but what's happening oh
yeah I got a wooden plank cool can I do
anything with this plank wooden planks
now I got a banna scheme is a bit I'm
not gonna lie to you man this games a
bit confusing I don't to be a dick about
it but there is such a thing as like
being too coy in a game you know you
don't need to just get me on the pirate
ship man let me start plundering and
stuff boot let's wear a dress as gender
is fluid these days can we do a dress
and a coat all right yeah I'm into it
okay great why what oh my god
oh my god see if these bro I want to
love you but you're hurting me bad here
you're hurting me bad see it thieves
you're hurting me bad just make things
easier all right here we go
okay never close your upper body shocked
enemies with your gut
walking the boss oh one yeah the
pcmasterrace they're super annoying but
you know what don't feed the trolls just
let them have their little [ __ ] session
all right here we go
I got a bounty skull that's cool I don't
know what I'd do with any of this stuff
what's happening got a cool bounty skull
I'm on a boat now what oh god Beth I'm
so sorry I know this is frustrating to
you what is going on in this game all I
want to do is sail a ship and shoot
people with cannons and plunder I
dropped the thing okay let's go use the
wheel here we go here we go all right
let's go let's go let's go let's get
this ship going all right I mean moving
do we have to undo the anchor oh this is
like a real simulator this is too real
waiting here maybe I have to undo
something the anchor I'll raise the
anchor here we go okay raise the anchor
this is harder than doing a real boat by
the way I can actually sail oh here we
go
all right raise the anchor I don't know
in the anchors okay
anchors race I can't seem to let go of
this banana but fine
set sail angle all right oh oh we're
good no no no no no we're going to oh
god we're going to the beach opposite
way ah now we're on the land god damn it
all right hold on well luckily I've got
my banana okay use the wheel all right
let's turn the goddamn boat around oh
now we're just on the beach it's like me
trying to back out of my underground
parking space
this is awful all right here we go all
right we're all right guys minute 19 and
we've managed to get on a boat and sail
away so just to reiterate first of all
we started out like a huge mountain in
the dark all right there was only
candles around we were naked we tried to
talk to a bartender didn't help us and I
was totally confused about that we have
a banana then we swam out to a mer man
who got us on a boat and then we tried
to put clothing on but it didn't quite
work and then we ran onto a beach and
now we're sailing how do we know you
have a hold about I don't know everyone
how do you guys know we have a whole you
know what we should do is go down let's
go under the water I mean let's go below
decks let's see if there's water coming
all right
oh [ __ ] no no wait oh my god were full
of water how did this happen how do we
plug the hole we crashed into the lint
how do we oh you know what we got a
plank we can we put a plank in the open
equipment chest
there's no okay oh my god this mess okay
oh yeah the kids cheer - is really gonna
help us am i dead
oh no I'm underwater [ __ ] wait you know
what I bet I have to do the planks
where's the where's my plank at put the
banana to the hole that's what she said
oh how do I use the planks didn't I pick
up like didn't I pick up like ten
thousand planks the [ __ ] is the plank
all right here we go all right let's do
it
patch it up oh this is what I want to
patch up repair hall there we go
preparing it baby okay it's going down
all right
but wait why does it keep coming back up
I'm basically just smacking the water
out of the boat oh I gotta hold it I'm
an idiot okay I'm gonna drown by the way
okay Kay hey there's somebody else in
here hey how's it going
don't shoot me though okay oh thanks
father helping thank God
alright oh thank the Lord whoever this
woman is thank you warm beverages thank
you is that her name warm beverages oh
my god this is so stressful okay okay
all right good we're back you know what
maybe this woman could just help me out
let's open the armory oh cool
how do I take this can I take it did I
get this that I get the sword this is
very unclear about how to get stuff cool
can I just take it like what man I don't
know dude that's the right thing to do
okay I have it I guess all right well
incredibly unclear alright here we go
I feel better holding my banana frankly
alright great
okay maybe she's driving us somewhere oh
thank god thank god you're here what no
why are you shooting me
we're beverage come on yeah
Elizabeth you're right the UI is very
confusing all right here we go
all right good all right we're doing
well whoo these are some rough waters
well me and my crew member here all
right
oh my god these are godly you know thank
God for a warm beverage yeah and I gotta
say it's a little ironic because growing
up my parents didn't put the beverages
in the fridge we only had warm beverages
so when I was a kid warm beverages I
love warm beverages and now I game
hollers I don't need to voice chat with
anyone trust me
all right cool all right oh here we go
something's happening we're a trip here
Kay all right here we go
the clouds are beautiful the water does
look awesome I agree you guys it's just
a very I can't figure out what to do
I don't know how to help here maybe I
did get on the cannon or something
I can't load the banana cannot load your
Hannah oh there's some bad guys okay
okay I picked up a chest okay wait dude
warm beverage just jump over more
members just abandon ship she's had it
man
okay where's more beverage going or
beverage is gone well I guess it's up to
me now
sigh teeth first I do cheese after warm
beverage I don't know man she's right
there are you know what maybe she put
the anchor down did she put the anchor
down oh she did okay well you know what
we don't want to strand her here that
seems a little mean the water makes you
want to punch a pirate baby okay doesn't
get hit left bumper picked them with
pick item with the right stick I don't
really have oh I don't have any
cannonballs I'm not a cannonball okay do
you think there's anything in these
chests Oh got it all right well we're
gonna let her do that and I'm just gonna
maybe look for some cannonballs less yet
in case somebody bad comes I want to
help out warm beverage cause warm
beverages help me out oh I don't have to
stay in the ship says mega star gaming
okay all right well let's jump overboard
whoo let's go swimming
you my banana all right oh cool look at
this ship all right let's get over there
[Music]
do this water it's so pretty how come I
don't move my one arm with the banana
while I'm swimming that doesn't make any
sense
turn chest it at the port our plane sea
of thieves it's I mean it's a little I'm
not gonna lie to you guys it's a little
tough the wreck of the howling beast
perfect so the recommends girlfriend
basically here we go all right you know
I'm just gonna say it I think if if this
thing's upside down maybe all the
treasure just fell down to the bottom of
the sea was like everything we just
empty out do I have like unlimited
health underneath the water cuz that's
pretty cool
[Music]
hit beetles Oh No
Oh that was really scary because that's
what's happened son man hey hey hey hey
hey wait hey yo more beverage
yeah we're beverage oh no oh come on god
damn it cool I didn't leave one beverage
oh no that's sucked Oh what's this I'm
on the ferry of the Dan okay now things
are getting interesting I like this this
is cool
whoa this is awesome am i a ghost pirate
now why didn't I start on the ferry of
the Damned this thing is awesome
look at this
look at this we got a wolf man ghost
[Music]
I can go and the fairy of the damn door
what's up
it's just off this is pretty cool
oh let's see what's in here
oh this looks like a portal to something
else I was just I was just looking for
the bathroom I think I found a portal to
the nether realm I don't know
emoji ghosts I'll come back right let's
go we got to find warm beverage and get
our revenge yeah but there's a banana
ghost I'm leaving says well I'm telling
you right now if I see warm beverage
she's dead going after ah there she is
ah ha ha where's my skull I'm gonna hit
her with this skull in the back of the
head there's no melee right I can't
figure out how to melee in this game so
do I have these things and this is so
hard there's no noise that says I picked
them up unless I already have them I
guess now see that here
like I don't get I don't understand how
this this game works oh here we go
alright good finally figured it out yo
why you got to leave me behind dude
alright fine she's learned her lesson
wait backstep apathy Inc says backstab
at the banana a weapons earned a
different thing sista TKO at seven well
now what do we do smartass yeah we're at
port what's up now huh I can't talk to
you cuz I'm chat on yeah yeah
lead the way I'll go do something I'll
help you out also I think a scrunchie
and a headbands a little much to come on
alright how do we do this let's go give
these chests to people right cool I'm
sunk so this is cool
[Music]
idk something one I think this is
multiplayer find me
Blair gamertag
and am I taking this somewhere I think I
have to go hey there's a little pig that
was pig oh oh man this game is way
cooler now it's got a pig in it it's
gonna be hard to play us not being able
to talk to your crew members got it
Jason Lyman well you know what I'm
having a pretty hard time anyway so oh
[Music]
wait is this just a random island oh
this is just a random Island why do I
have the chest
dammit this is the best game of
Microsoft dart garrix one oh not sure
about that if warm beverage leaves again
I'm gonna lose my mind yeah what up
[Music]
what's up how do I get back on that ship
alright I'm pulling back on I'll just
climb this ladder here perfect alright I
brought the chest back they'll be happy
to know what are we doing here oh you
know what
ah wait warm beverage is gonna look for
some treasure and I'm gonna help here we
go we're finally looking for treasure
alright let's go
warm beverage always disappointed with
the threat mod f7 I kill these fish hey
come here
can I kill this fish yeah alright well
let's look around the silent oh can I
get that chicken don't worry I got
supper warm beverage you just oh wait oh
wait
warm beverage is holding a thing if
treasure you seek then heed my word
Canon Cove should be preferred at the
forbidden tomes rarely light blooms dig
nine paces South by Southwest each trip
at the forbidden tones light rarely
blooms dig nine paces South by Southwest
treasure Luke look out
I just saved your ass yeah I just saved
your ass buddy all right
nine pieces South by Southwest of the
forbidden tombs
yeah she's got great grammar I agree all
right light rarely blooms all right you
know what stuffs starting to get kind of
cool at the forbidden tomes what are the
forbidden tomes
I wash the skillet and I had to laugh
who wait light rarely blooms there's
there should be a light here by
Southwest
forbidden tones yes dark as hell at this
game
don't lie it took 30 minutes to get
above it fair enough ooh you know I
don't know something one says it's so
funny after user skeletons attacking us
at video games you now see these bone
monsters as frail most likely the
weakest enemies in the game when bones
are extremely durable on the hardest
part of a human body okay but tones
bones don't have a good tensile strength
they have a good compression strength
you know I'm saying it is easy to break
a bone like this it's hard to break it
you know what I'm saying it's it's like
so yes and no I think and also it's
really I don't know how much of we're
not really breaking the bones as we are
the bonds that hold the bones together
which are not that oh good more bananas
great that's what I need is more bananas
cool that's what I want more bananas Hey
look what I found
yep Oh cannonballs that's good you need
it soon that's right
I had no balls and now I have three so
use that they have no tendon that we
could fall yeah exactly cost it can I
agree with you so really it's not we're
not breaking the bones we're breaking
the the [ __ ] that holds the bones
together I don't know do I need to have
my [ __ ] out here my shovel okay I got my
shovel
nine paces south by south but the light
rarely blooms is that a skeleton over
there looks like one all right so wait
let me pull out my this game is little
okay South by Southwest nine paces here
we go
let's see one two three four five six
seven skeleton a nine I'm gonna dig
right here all right all right I don't
see anything so far nothing like a game
where you're digging is basically what I
had to do my entire childhood my dad was
super into landscaping my dad's best
favorite thing was to order like like
300 pounds of mulch and not tell me and
just one day I would want to go over to
my friends house like a Saturday a big
truck would pull up back up into the
driveway just dump a whole thing of
mulch
then he'd be like guess what we're doing
today and I was like spreading mulch
around he's like yep and then we never
had the right tools
am I getting anything so I'd always have
to wear like a fishing goggles like it
would get my mouth and we never bought
paper masks because why would we it was
Michigan I thought was South by
Southwest Oh South by southeast let me
kill this any hole real quick oh whoops
I guess you can't just hit him with a
shovel oh I thought it was South by
South East
oh it was just East all right ha ha well
this is South by southeast that's where
I went uh-oh oh wait I guess it's up
here I was totally wrong oh so it's
maybe up here somewhere
oh wait here's Hey
sure that Jesus
goddamn skeleton over here it is isn't
it yep were you at where you at
oh damn it now I got us restarting it
this is maybe this is row you know what
I should eat is a banana
finally the bananas coming in handy yeah
how do I use this banana well these
bananas really do what's roblox cheesy
nips alright yeah I'm looking dude hey
no show it to me again
this chair and a banana friend don't
even peel it nope
all right is it South by southeast but
let me see the thing in South by
southeast that's what I'm doing all
right what's the button I have to hold
down that tells my steps
all right I think it's here man find
some goddamn treasure don't you think
it's here nine paces right see look
she's taken two so I guess I don't go
deeper I just go and we're really
destroying this person's garden oh every
time I say bones nook Asuka is cat comes
up to them and cuddles them bones bones
bones bones bones do I know the beetles
yes Ralphie gave me I know the Beatles
not personally but I did meet Ringo
Starr once well I said hide over the
hallway nod back I guess that's not
meeting him hold RB to check the map Oh
deidre habit we're trolling nuke asuka's
cat Oh God
Rexel shop no man I feel like we've gone
nine paces maybe I'm wrong
yeah I know I I'm looking at that thing
too man
oh I have that thing too let's look at
it if treasure you seek then heed my
word Canon Co should be preferred at the
forbidden tomes tombs oh maybe it's
tombs lightly rarely blooms dig 9 pieces
up by southeast treasure nearby looms
maybe this isn't a - we were thinking
about that idea I don't see a tomb here
man I know I'm gonna look around some
more
I think there's another - somewhere else
maybe this is the tomb light rarely
blooms are we sure this is the tomb warm
beverage tones 9 pieces could be 18
steps Oh paces could be counted with one
step of one foot Oh 18 steps okay all
right
wait where ah everything this game is
weirdly scary to me okay here we go
guys how would I make would I be a good
player or not and be honest I mean I
would be like I think captain white
beard right what's a good what do you
think my good pirate name would be like
captain snowflake it's not really gonna
strike fear into the hearts of people oh
[ __ ]
see this makes me feel like if they're
close to a tomb you know Jesus I got to
get my man out I got to get my banana
out I gotta get my Nana out see I feel
like there's a tomb up here now her tome
you don't feel like it's like up here
somewhere see could be up here right
although you know what you figure the
fires probably light really blows I do
like you know what I will say I really
do like the the riddle aspect of this
game is cool yes captain banana
captain nanner they're still digging
over here maybe this is the tomb I don't
see a tomb over here
I use it tone oh but there's no book
over here either what still digging a oh
look at this what's this aha
I don't know this could be something all
right we got a clue all right so let's
go south by southwest from here right
where's my thing
south-southeast yeah oh so it's through
that rock
it seems tarde well maybe it's around
the rock maybe it's like over here maybe
it's like up here you know right it's
not gonna be through a rock that's
stupid
I guess that's the only real thing on
this island is that oh what's this
that's more cannonballs I always take
more bananas it's in a cave yes yeah I
think we haven't found I don't think
it's that thing man I think it's like
somewhere else that we haven't quite
discovered yeah I know warm beverages
I'm looking around you show me that
thing one more time
roblox if you walk to the compass you
energy actually low like that the
forbidden rope is there a cave by the
fireplace I didn't see one dig the rock
maybe I should just shine just dig in
front of that thing
I'm looking for a cave or something I
still think it's like a tomb why no I
mean we did nine paces and I'm pretty
sure she didn't 18 did you find
something I know don't show it I know I
know Jim I know I don't think it's there
I know going down here I think it's some
let's see we didn't really search the
beach honestly I'm looking also don't
worry Oh what's this what's this could
be here right could be somewhere down
here southeast from here what do you
think should we do we dare dig here
no graphic tee click-click Adelphia
because we're playing a pirate game and
I don't really have a pirate shirt but I
were all black and I also forgot to
bring one so I'm not ignoring the
directions a c7z so I just we've dug
warm beverage was drinking was drinking
was digging was was digging up in this
other area but I think it's somewhere
else we haven't found the tomes
or the tombs by the way blooms
I think it's tombs I think they
misspelled tunes we haven't really found
the tombs so I'm digging around
somewhere else where I think it might be
but it's not here either
I think we just have to do some more
searching
it's the twos where the light rarely
blooms what's up here Oh what's this ah
I see many more right here yeah could be
this way huh
smartass this could be it too right
do we think that it's we're gonna split
when we see the ground it's gonna be
there in the index or something I am old
and I went gray early so you're both
right
tome now in a book yeah but they're no
goddamn books in this island we just got
to keep looking man
there's no book up here right in amo
chest let's see any freaking books
anywhere where's the cave books in a
cave where's the cave well let's go back
down let's look for a cave I've been
screaming about a cave let me see a God
okay get off my jock wanna see anybody
know where a cave is anywhere I see
there's no cave here right I don't mind
losing ah there's a cave right here why
don't we look in the cave where's that
okay where's the tome at ah here it is
all right from Tom's we got some tomes
right here perfect warm beverage why
aren't you looking around here here we
go already 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 ah
yes we find some treasure oh my god this
is awesome
take that warm beverage you keep shoving
that dumb thing in my face yeah your boy
found the treasure
[ __ ] boy found the marauders chest
what's up we just got to get off this
dumb island with these stupid pigs and
chickens and all that crap alright
[Music]
all right back to the ship
there we go
all right just gotta remember where I
parked the ship yes prawns Adam thank
you thank you everybody for your help
and a big one thank you to my partner
warm beverage yeah no [ __ ] warm beverage
god damn it I don't think we're beverage
is a person I think warm beverages at AI
right oh we got a little piggy
would you get a pig if you could yes
well what if it was growing to a big big
big pig friend captain nanners forever
dude captain nanners forever
[Music]
now we just got to find our goddamn boat
where's the myrrh man when you need him
you know there's a lot of gunfire oh I
hear if I die before I get to this boat
I'm gonna be really upset and that up
and that would exactly be what would
happen to me we can't die before we get
to the boat
we're Beveridge you better not leave
without me dude I know this is crazy I
just gotta stop for a quick and an ER
[Music]
one more nanner
you're gonna protect me warm beverage or
what all right let's get back on it yeah
later sucker on that ladder we did it
all right let's get out of here I'm
obviously the digger and you're the
pilot let's do it okay I guess I'm the
pilot and you're the person who looks to
the table that's fine don't worry about
it
raise that anchor baby
more baggage just gonna look at me run
let's get out of here
good skeleton swim I hope guys oh no oh
no see this is what happens never let me
steer a boat cuz I don't know what I'm
doing
oh wait wrong way wrong way wrong way
yeah more beverage is the table er and
I'm the digger put the loot in the hole
what does that mean alright let's get
out of here okay just gonna stand there
you adjust the sails or what I always
Park your boat pointing away from the
island yeah no [ __ ] we've another hole
how is that possible why did I raise the
anchor what are you talking about
schematics 70 for me to leave oh wait
where's there more is there more
treasure wait are we sailing should we
not be sailing away wait do we go back
oh there's warm beverage upset at me
this is what happens if you play a game
requires communication on the ability to
check you're ruining more beverage
experience as warm beverage is a person
no it's you know what it's unclear all
right I'm just gonna oh I'm gonna let
warm beverages take charge even though
by the way who found the treasure
captain nanners not warm beverages thank
you I got holes oh no do i how many
holes I got we got some holes right here
no problem I got some pair of that hole
yep I have a feeling warm manners it's
just gonna take us right back to the
ship sucks by the way ship is sprouting
holes right left oh wait I should put
the thing I see I should put the
treasure down here don't just leave it
willy-nilly up on the deck like some he
didn't check the new map okay good idea
[Music]
all right I sort out let's check that
new map okay
all right where we going
Oh Wanderers refuge or no I guess not
well that's a big wave yeah
No Name warm beverage is just random
enough to be either a I generator or a
real person remove water Pham okay
look at this this is very pretty look at
that sunset bet oh look at that sunset
oh it's so pretty all right well little
dark you know this game could stand some
warming up we're lightening up I don't
how to do that though I make the game
lighter can that happen
the game get lighter here we go can the
game be lighter here let's do a little
high I what warm beverages wait warm
beverages are you watching
well played rolls on deck laughing look
out I well played know what's happening
oh my god I think more beverage is
having a stroke or warm beverages is oh
yeah or maybe all the messages just came
through for some reason I think warm
beverages in AI that's what I think this
is not the talk of a real person warm
beverages call me captain manners if
you're a real person
oh god
we're Bevis trolling i didn't warm bad
is it I think more babies a robot
oh no what I'm just losing their mind I
think I got a person with dementia here
all right here we go
it's so dark oh my god we're going down
are we you seem just fine to me oh you
know what I guess we should do is take
my bucket out I got some water
tedious business throwing this out it's
freaking dark put the water back where
it belongs
it is so dark on this ship I can I could
definitely use a little bit to feel the
view Wow
okay no way to make it lighter okay no
problem she's a real person how do you
know
oh sorry tech bean probably no more
beverage is a real person
how do we know musa ball I agree Kyle
Jones more beverage is too hot for me
are we looking at
my god it's so dark in here use math
table alright we're going back to the
Wanderers refuge
all right
Oh Oh I'm coming this way all right I'm
coming dude okay I got my [ __ ] out Hey
yeah I'm following you
let's go I think warm beverages is
pissed at me use the lantern there's no
text chat only presets she's not acting
AI Li well I don't know
all right I'm following him following Oh
guys it's one o'clock I think we got to
call it we thought you know what we
found some you know what I found I found
some treasures let's be honest the track
in the chat you guys found some treasure
I'm gonna make friends with warm
beverages and you know what then we're
gonna see if they are an AI or not and
if they're not maybe we'll play with
them again and if they are then we won't
guys thank you so much for joining us
the game has met see if these it's not
now it I will say it is really fun yeah
I'm dumb once you get the hang of it
it's great and if you have a partner
that may or may not be AI and yeah or
you can read compasses or you know how
to pace yes or you know how to use your
nanners that's the most important thing
I think we figured out today being a
pirate is all about having fresh bananas
on here it is just like in the olden
time that's true a leaky would better
make sure to watch the show tonight John
app it says on the show as is Krysten
Ritter as is whose arm is your guest
roses with Nicky Romero absolutely our
other show tonight and tune in by the
way Saturday I'm doing a new dinner to
video game on twitch.tv slash Aaron
blare it's gonna be a instead of attack
on Titan a snack
I don't I'm gonna make more d'oeuvres
I'm not sure what kind haven't figured
out what kind yet so watch that
twitch.tv slash Erin Blair thank you all
for joining us watch the show tonight
we'll see you guys next week see you
later bye
[Music]